欢迎收听股爱,我是孙孟公
本期节目由雨伞王赞助
投资最怕什么?不是股票跌
而是买到那种看起来很便宜的股票
结果买了一直跌一直坏掉
一直跌一直坏掉
其实雨伞也是
很多人买伞都只看价格
结果一年买三只五只
最后花得更多
雨伞王算是少数把雨伞当成耐用品在做的品牌
全台超过33间门市
最大的特色是终身免费维修服务
融资断头你只能被迫出场
雨伞断头还可以找雨伞王维修进场
真的是很幸福
最近台股创新高
股市超热
天气更热
太阳超毒
中国就要去替补真的会挂掉
所以大家一定要做好防晒
结果雨伞王最近为了提高本益比
也跨界转型
推出了遮阳挡雨降温保暖的新商品
我觉得真正每天都会用到的科技
其实是防晒
毕竟CPU涨停不一定赚得到
紫外线你每天一定照得到
Big Red的降温防晒伞
可以带来降温12度的体感
极轻薄防晒外套
外出防晒透气超舒适
有超帅的SuperThink超薄折叠墨镜
也有为眼镜组准备的套进太阳眼镜
都能够有效保护自己的眼睛
毕竟每天盯盘已经伤眼了
出门至少不要再让太阳补刀
好了大概就是这样
以上所有的商品
报上梦工Chika的名字
都可以想最佳优惠
透过资讯网古埃专属的连结
输入我们的推荐代码GOOAYE
不限期间想限定商品89折优惠
但比消費滿999再想超取免運費
提供給所有需要的朋友們參考
大概在一兩集前
有一位聽眾在QA跟我講說
可不可以去全聯看一下
有沒有自己還蠻喜歡的紅酒或是白酒
來跟大家稍微分享一下
當然不想讓自己感覺像是一個臭酒鬼
因為我現在正在研究這個淋浴相關的內容
自己也買了一個酒櫃
這個酒櫃從以前到現在一直都是滿的狀態
就即便是用很高速在消耗了
可是都還是持續有新的東西在補
像我現在我的酒櫃就還欠17個空間
這什麼意思
就是我後面有17瓶要進來
然後現在是滿的
所以我就必須要再快一點
所以在這樣的狀況之下
當然就沒有辦法把每一個都喝完
最大多數的狀況就是
我可能就是喝一點
然後其他的分給別人
然後不然就是甚至拿去餵水草
如果沒那麼喜歡的
就不會強迫自己把它喝掉
因為自己來的目的
並不是要把自己灌醉
而是想去嘗遍各式各樣的口味
當聽眾給我這樣子的任務的時候
其實我自己也是非常好奇
就是在千年可不可以找到有趣的东西
那我相信一定是可以啦
因为像我自己岳母的男朋友呢他本身在意大利就是去做酒庄的那他的酒的售價大概就是幾百塊到千塊之間他也在意大利好幾次都挑出了非常好喝的酒給我們喝
大概也就是落在幾百塊到一兩千塊之間
但是這些酒其實到台灣它的價格都會相對的貴一點
我自己是覺得在台灣這邊
目前我自己試下來的一個甜蜜的位置
大概是落在一兩千塊左右
這個是對絕大多數人來說可能是CP值比較好的一個位置
那當然1000塊以下也是有很多選項
只是他可能就是喝起來比較像是水
就是他並沒有可能比較豐富的尾韻
然後再來就是香味可能會差強人意
那如果說就算是有香味的
像一些大家非常喜歡的很常見的那些牌子
我們就不要去點名人家
但是我也是一開始覺得說這個東西喝起來蠻順
以前不懂的時候
可是現在稍微的去走了一輪之後
就覺得那個聞起來是非常的人工的味道
所以就比較不喜歡
那你可能就在1000塊以下
就比較有機會去買到這樣子的東西
那大概1000塊到3000塊之間
我覺得就是一個蠻好的甜蜜點這樣
那在群聯這邊呢
不是群聯啦
不是8299
全聯喔
全聯這裡呢
他的蠻多久大概是落在1000塊以下的一個價位
所以呢我就去稍微的試了一下
但因為他的選項真的蠻多的啦
那我相信每個全聯可能也會有不一樣的展示
那所以呢
為了要加速自己的效率
我的做法是
我還是先打開我自己平常會去使用的一些紅酒APP
因為要去管理自己的酒窖
知道裡面有什麼東西嗎
那所以呢就用那個去掃描了一下酒標
我先塞掉大概就是可能評分在80分以下
那其實評分在80分以下很難啦
就代表你可能真的要爛到一個極限才在那個位置
那當然不是代表說我們要跟著評分去做事情
只是說因為時間是有限的
所以我們先把一些可能很明顯的雷先把它弄掉之後呢
那剩下的我就去挑我喜歡的
那其實我目前最喜歡的是
柏根蒂或是有些麻松也是布根蒂
就是我覺得這個是最符合我的口味的
就是它的酒味可能是沒有這麼重
比較著重在一些花香 草香之類的
這是我比較喜歡的風味
一開始我剛入坑的時候
因為名氣最大的就是波爾多那幾個酒莊
像什麼拉菲
因為我在看港片的一定知道82年的拉菲
我家我也有82年的拉菲
我喝完一支我再買一支
但是一開始喝的時候是喜歡這些東西
可是我自己覺得波爾多的味道是比較偏重一點
所以我就沒有那麼喜歡
我還是比較喜歡可能像是伯根蒂這樣的風格
當然伯根蒂因為它比較稀缺的一個關係
所以一級緣特級緣
特別是知名的酒莊
現在都是炒作到一個
非常難以接近的價格
可是不代表你一定要去買這個才可以喝到伯根底的一些風味如果你今天去走一些村莊級的選項或者是一些可能沒有這麼知名度的酒莊但是因為伯根底他畢竟是跟地塊的也就是可能像一些特級元異級元
上面會有很多人在那邊耕種
理論上當然只有兩派的說法
一派的說法就是說
其實釀酒師本身會決定的口味很大
另外一派的說法
特別是有很多大師的說法是
我們只是忠實的去反映這個地塊
該有的一個味道
所以釀酒師
如果你有自己的太多色彩在裡面
反而不是一個好事情
總之我自己也是比較偏向是
地塊的一個信徒
當然有些釀酒者非常強大的
像樂號的酒就是真的是很厲害
只是當然它價格也是貴的不可思議
那它種出來的東西
就真的比別人香很多
你也不知道到底發生什麼事情
即便是在同一個地塊
可是絕加多數的狀況之下
你用地塊去選
我覺得是OK的
就沒有什麼太大的問題
波爾多的話就是跟著酒莊
所以如果說預算比較夠的
你就可以去買它一均的酒
如果預算沒有這麼夠的
像那些五大他們都有他的二軍的酒
那二軍的酒其實差距也不會到太大
是一個可以撿便宜的選項
再來我自己是比較喜歡右岸
就是一開始在長輩推坑之下
他們都推我左岸
但後來發現說長輩他們可能
你知道他有些味道喝不到
就像是我可能喜歡喝18天跟金牌
那長輩就說他們喜歡喝傳統的台皮
他們覺得這才有味道
所以一樣的道理
就是我可能年紀還沒有到
所以我後來就覺得說
左岸的東西都是太重了
酒味太濃
所以真的要喝就是他一定要放很久
他可能要30年40年以上的
我才會覺得說OK
可是三四十年又有可能會放到
已經有一些金針菇尾部的味道
有些人喜歡那個味道可是我非常的不喜歡
所以後來對左岸就害了
我比較喜歡右岸的就是Pomerul
然後跟Merlot葡萄他所釀出來的一些紅酒
那當然右岸的東西有蠻多
也是被炒到很靠北的價格
那如果說我們今天進入新世界
就是往美國那邊去的話
那美國這邊我就有很多很喜歡的
那像一個什麼Mount Brave
勇敢山
那也是可能兩三千塊而已
我覺得它的味道就很好
那貴的話
像Screaming Eagle我真的就是還蠻喜歡的
但是我後來最喜歡的是一個Harland
它大概就是Screaming Eagle的半價而已
可是味道非常好
那Screaming Eagle的話我覺得它的平替版本
就是你可以選那個Cask 23
它是還蠻不錯的
再來呢如果說你覺得整個
那怕也是不便宜的話
你可以再往南美去選
我覺得那個味道其實
並不會說差很遠
都是比較偏向是那種水果炸彈的感覺
就是滿滿的果味非常的濃郁
那南美洲就有超級多便宜師匯的選項
像之前跟大家推的那個Catina
就是南美的一個我覺得這樣蠻厲害的酒莊
那我就直接來跟大家講我在全聯挑到了哪些東西那首先有一個是DV Katina Malbec我覺得它喝起來的味道是非常的乾淨的
就是說它有當然各種濃厚的果香
一點點那種黑色水果的味道
這不是我在那邊瞎掰
我特別去買了一本那種味道書
然後就整天在那邊聞那個味道
黑里子 一點點紫羅蘭
巧克力的話可能有些人聞得到
有些人聞不到
我覺得好 當然問我老婆的話可能聞得到
再來就是一些橡木的味道
口感算是很飽滿的一個選項
這個東西在這個價位
就是可能幾百塊來說是非常的物超所值
就是你要感受一下這種水果轟炸的話
我覺得它是一個還蠻屌的選項
第二個是Luca Laborde
它是一個Cira
就是用Cira這個葡萄所做出來的東西
它的香味的辨識度就是還蠻高的
多了一點點
就是他們把它稱為是匹格味
它的口感也是偏濃
但是不會說太重
然後再來就是
我覺得它丹寧是還蠻結實的
尾韻是相對長一點的
以這個價位的酒來說
你要有比較長的尾韻其實是比較困難的
簡單來講就是說
像我自己喜歡的一些酒莊
我會故意買它最入門跟它最貴的
一般最貴的就是說
味道的細膩度跟精緻程度會拉到很高
有點像是說你今天去買一個
怎麼講就可能幾千塊以上的毛衣
然後到你去買什麼Loropiana
老實講啦
對絕大多數人來講你已經分不出差別
你真的要很認真去喝
你才喝出差別
有點像這樣子的味道
所以基本上你只要挑到一個
夠好的酒莊跟不錯的地塊
你就很難輸了
那在網上要去分出來就不容易
但可能像是尾韻這個東西
就是說它的味道拉得長不長
這個對我來講再來蠻明顯可以分得出來
它是相對長
以這個價位來講算是一個非常好的選項
然後去配一些比較重口的東西
我覺得是還蠻適合的
所以可能是一個蠻令人興奮的Sirah
算是還蠻推薦的
然後再來西班牙有一款叫做Bardo's Reserva
這個我自己也算是還蠻喜歡的
它是Tempernil
然後可能大一點Carbonate Sauvignon去做出來的
那是用那種好像是全新的橡木桶
去收成一陣子之後才把它放出來
那它就是有一點那種黑醋粒的味道
然後有一點點雪松
我感覺是這樣子
那薄荷我上網查蠻多人說有
可是我是喝不太出薄荷的味道
但總之這也是一支蠻認真
然後是現代風格的酒
那以這個價錢來說
它算是給你非常多的東西
所以這也是一個蠻讚的選項
然後再來就是兩個白的
因為我覺得有紅的就好白的
首先是一個叫做FamiMath
應該是這樣念的
F-A-M-I-L-L-E
M-A-S-S-E
後面就是法文
超難念的
Tara
不會
反正就是
總之你用Famimas
應該就可以找到
然後Borgon Chardonnay
它這是Chardonnay
2022年份的
這是一個比較小型的家族酒莊
我是用老藤去做的
它是用不鏽鋼槽
加橡木桶去做配合
大概可能是熟成的
大概10個月左右
它的香氣就是蠻典型的
大家可能白酒會喜歡的
像是什麼青蘋果 白桃
然後一點點的榛果
然後還有一點點的碎石
我後來才知道這個叫碎石
因為像我之前就喝一個雙雞的酒
那時候還有一些長輩以為說
這個酒可能是壞掉了
因為怎麼會這麼黃
然後我說聞起來超像鞭炮的味道
然後後來來說這個鞭炮的味道
就是他們後來把它稱為是碎石
或者說礦物的味道
以前有一個說法是說
這種礦物的味道
應該是在土壤裡面有很多的
可能石頭或什麼的
然後釀出來就是這樣子
只是後來
因為上次我去參加品酒會的時候
裡面有一個老師
他就去做了很多的說明
他說最後面他們有發現
那個味道其實不是說什麼
葡萄可以去從土壤裡面吸到
那些石頭的味道
他是沒有辦法的
他可能是發酵的時候
會產生那樣子的一個味道
總之這個我覺得應該是
蠻多人都會喜歡的
用一個超級便宜
極表快的價格
就可以當成是一個配餐
可能還配海鮮在蠻適合
其實在還蠻順口的 Charonnet
是一個可能可以參考的選項
最後一個是Mateau Sauvignon Blanc
這個就是一個我覺得絕大多醇一定都會喜歡的東西
如果真的要入門的話用這個應該最簡單
因為酒味沒有很重
那就把它冰到冰箱
就讓它很冰就對了
你不要吊它說什麼
12度14度
不要讓它變超冰的喝就不會有問題
那它的香味就是非常的
我覺得絕大多醇會喜歡
有點像美酒的感覺
什麼可能一些檸檬啊
一些青草味啊
然後再來就是水果百香果什麼
這個你都會感覺到酸度高又很乾淨
可是它有一個小缺點就是
他放一段時間
他就會就類似那種老婆跟弟一樣
味道很快就會散掉
但是如果說你剛開屏直接冰冰的下去
我覺得這應該是蠻多人
會在夏天可以做的一個選項
就你不要想太多
罵的便宜就直接把它拿來灌
這是OK的
所以以上就是我在全聯的一些小發現
那當然不要在後面就立刻在叫我說什麼
已經有人說你去美聯社
因為我之前PO現動
你去美聯社
然後你去什麼加勒服
或者說好事多
那有空再去
因為我家就像我剛剛前面講的
那個list是太長了
所以對或許只有有空氣氛對再來試試看看但我其實覺得蠻有趣有時候聽眾給我出一個任務我也沒有想過說我可以這樣去做嘗試總之就是一個蠻有趣的發現在這邊稍微的跟大家簡單分享一下
希望大家飲酒要是兩位成年不要亂喝酒
大家這樣
謝謝我們今天節目的話題
那最近的盤面應該讓蠻多人很有感覺
至少我自己也開始去吃了一些回檔
但並沒有覺得說有很大的傷害
因為這一波從上次修正的第一點
就差不多6月的上旬
最低大概是摸到42,000點
然後後來也噴到了48,000多點
所以又是短短的時間內就拉了6,000多點
現在稍微的拉回
甚至連一些主要的均線都還沒有跌破
所以感覺就是可能創新高周的一個休息
當然有些人可能會把這個視為是一個假突破
但這樣看其實是不對的
所以假突破可能是
今天已經是盤整盤了很長的一段時間
然後突然間拉上去
接著直接灌破往下又再破底
這個才會算是一個假突破
以現在這個狀況看起來比較像是說
就是漲多拉回來
因為前面從42000拉上來
也是直接又拉了6000點
所以這個盤子非常恐怖的
說不定後面休息一下之後
就再繼續的往上噴射
很難講
這一波當然大家會想要去找一些下跌的理由
有人說可能是美銀發了一個報告說
升息會升三次什麼的
但是我自己覺得觸發點
可能是韓國人造成的
因為韓國人大家都知道說
他們的指數下已經變成像是
那種全民大賭場的感覺
那韓國人他們很厲害的點是說
他們並不是只會影響到自己國內的人
他們會跑到外面
像之前去搞TESTA去搞Panter
然後或是搞一些鬼谷小票
或是Wall Street Bets上面的一些標的
然後加密貨幣什麼
反正每次只要韓國人群聚的地方
後面就是很容易會有那種瞬間的爆炸產生
這個瞬間爆炸什麼產生呢
我今天剛剛早上在跟一些朋友聊天的時候
我就說其實這一波有點像是
那時候Archegos爆仗的時候
大家不知道你記不記得Archegos不要晃
那時候我跟大家介紹這個故事
那他也是含義的
反正總之就是它用大量的槓桿去搞一些標的
然後最後面因為有一些標的爆炸
就連帶的它可能就要瘋狂的去砍倉一些東西
然後去觸發一個連鎖效應
一個人就有可能會造成這樣子的影響
像說韓國一堆
然後再買那種槓桿ETF買到爆炸的
他們確實是有機會造成一些那種全球性的影響
所以我的體感是比較偏向說
感覺是韓國那邊先開始大大暴跌之後
然後後來全球的一些市場就跟著被影響
甚至在台灣這邊有些人講說
什麼韓國股市在跌
可是我心中想的是
韓國股神跌到底干我們屁事
但可能就是有一些心情上會連動
看到一些那種
韓國的大型巨頭突然間那邊屌摔然後之後指數出現一些熔斷有些人可能就覺得緊張就想把東西丟出來但我自己覺得這一波並沒有找到一些solid的理由去解釋老實說我們的聽眾都知道說
我們在下跌的時候
不用花太多時間去解釋為什麼下跌
因為你解釋了半天
後面V上來
你就是把自己的臉打到爛掉
像是可能在6月上旬的這一波回檔
那時候也是一堆人跟你一堆說法
那講了半天
你現在就回頭看他們的說法
你不覺得說就很好笑
就是未復心持強說愁
明明就沒有事情
然後你一定要把它講得很嚴重
但其實每個人都一定會對市場有一些評論或是看法
所以我意思是說不要把話踩死
因為終究你就是在市場裡面要持續的做多
才會賺到錢
終究是要這樣子
所以每次的修正你可以稍微的去做一些調整
你可以稍微的去找一些理由
來自駕一下自己的邏輯
可是千萬不要因為這樣子
然後滿手放空
因為蠻多人這樣做
你就想過去的幾年績效一定都不是太好
總之我會覺得說這波
沒有辦法找到一個像樣的修正理由
比較平常說可能就是漲多的一個拉回休息
拉回的幅度也很大
可是也不要忘記上去也很多
上去了6000點
所以這樣下來一下還OK
在過去的幾天
我自己也產生一些想法
我第一個想法就是說
會不會大家終於要密底瓜康
要往台積電裡面去跑
因為在過去有沒有注意到
數個交易日
像是被動元件
或是功率元件
都開始出現了一些回檔
但今天被動元件又再一次的
又轉強了
像是國具
基本上側破修正跟沒有跌到一樣
然後其他的一些被動元件
其實都是相對的強勢
在整個盤面來講
功率元件就在過去已經判一陣子
然後最近的兩天也開始出現休息
可是整體來看
他們的型態都還是非常漂亮的一個
多頭的結構
所以自己是不會覺得說這種東西
我必須要把它清藏掉
就只是因為有一個小回檔產生
但是就是會擔心說
會不會在這一波的轉換之後
大家終於要躲進去台積電
所以在前幾天我自己也有去試著
就把一些東西丟掉
然後換進去台積電
當然台積電也是根子吃回檔
只是它回檔的幅度就沒有大加大
可是在今天盤中
就是剛才我想一想
我又覺得
因為又在這跟身邊朋友討論
我就說我感覺就是TSM一定要上的
可是問題是就感覺中小沒有死透
所以本來買了蠻多的TSM
又把它稍微再降一點點
又再弄回去中小
所以這一波操作
我自己也覺得比較沒有一個邏輯
比較偏向是一個感受的東西
就是前面你看到一些回答產生
那想說OK
我要先躲進台積電
就按照本來的規劃
可是當你發現說
其實好像中小沒有死掉的時候
就把它拉出來
就可能稍微的閃掉一點崩
可是我覺得對整體的部位的影響不大
反正該吃的回檔
全部都還是有吃到
所以就再繼續的先回去中小可能我要等到台積電這波再一次的往上過小波段的新高我就會覺得說再去介入吧可是現階段會覺得反正既然修正大家都一起來修正
他也沒有特別好像說很扛的感覺
所以感覺我本來前一兩天認為說
垃圾盤會出現
可是我現在看就覺得垃圾盤感覺不會出現
所以就再一次的跑回去中小裡面
接下來最近在市場上面
偏向發哥的話題是比較多一點
我們就簡單的來講一下
首先是發哥的漲價性
這個應該蠻多人都有看到
就新聞上已經有把它爆出來了
那它並沒有去載明說
要去調漲的晶片的項目跟幅度
所以一般我們就把這個視為是
可能全產品線都有機會會去做調整
那這個調整可能不會是一個均衣價
就可能也是按照說不同的客戶
會有不同的一個幅度
就像是我們可能在被動元件所看到的一個現象一樣
那當然這件事情呢
它對公司一定是一個加分項
那很多人可能就吸反射就說
那為什麼那股價沒有漲是不是利多出盡什麼
沒有我覺得是因為前面真的漲很多
就前面真的漲非常多
所以後面的一些利多不一定推得上去
就類似說可能像NVIDIA
它有很多好消息
那可是不一定推得上去
因為畢竟真的是已經推很多
但有可能後面假設盤面的結構轉變
那市場開始喜歡大型股的話
就有可能會把這個漲價性的故事
就拿出來炒
這個是有機會的
那總之呢
就是這個對於整個公司的財務數字來說
我覺得就是一個加分項
是一個蠻不錯的訊號
重點是說你漲得動客戶
客戶給你漲
這個就是一個好事情
那再來就是大家應該有看到
郭敏奇有去貼說
連發哥這邊有一個新的晶片有拿到
就Google要給他收了
叫做Trigger Fish
這個Trigger Fish
我們稍微都去做了一下調查
去問了一下
其實這算是一個非常早期階段的東西
就是一般來說
像我們在市場上跟大家分享的東西都是
你可能已經是有看到
它有一個roll map跑出來
已經有一些狀況
才會跟大家去講說
可能後面有什麼契機可以去注意
但這個真的是還在
非常early face的一個東西
那嚴格上來說
它並不是說
额外再去拉出一颗
就是那种stand alone的晶片
它比较平常是用本来的晶片
去做一些调整
可能在memory这边去做一些
加量加料之类的
那所做出来的一颗
所以它没有办法
就是单一的去评量
说它可能会多多少量
我们可以把它视为说
跟前面的那一颗
算是包在一起
就是triggerfish
然后跟前面
不管是zebra或是homo
就是联发科这一条线
你可以把它算成是一起
不会因为说triggerfish
然后就额外就多出很多市场
可以这样去想象
但是其实可以代表说
他有辦法在Google這邊再額外去拿到案子
那一定就是在開發上面是相對的
還蠻順利的
所以才會被Award一些東西
所以這個就是稍微的不同於像前面
Block Kong老闆所講的
他說這些都是
就是像小屁孩一樣
在後面隨意不管是MARFIA
或是聯發科都是
那看來這些小屁孩
真的都是有去獲得一些時機
也不要說我們要去挑戰博通
或是要把博通踩下去
但他們確實是有打出自己的一個市場
所以這個Triggerfish
就稍微簡單跟大家講一下
它就是一個
反正你想像是加強版的晶片
它並不是額外在拉一個東西出來
反正在博通這邊
就真的有新東西出來
我不知道有沒有在節目跟大家講過
但反正就稍微的快速的複習一下
我們都知道說
博通在第八代有看到他的東西
可是第九代大家發現說他的東西怎麼不見了
大概在幾個月前的節目
我跟大家聊到說
你去觀察它Rawment好像少了一顆東西
然後後來那個東西有跑出來
叫做Wellfish
他其實就用前一個fish
然後去把它變成是雙拼的晶片
二拼一
所以這可能是在載版這邊
有機會可以找到一些機會的東西
那他就是
作為是他的下一代去做採用
所以最後面就是去解決了
我們這些市場人士本來心中的一個問題
奇怪怎麼博通被跳過了一代
他沒有被跳過
它就是有新的產品的產生
所以大概是這樣子
再來我們也有去注意到說
在被動元件這邊
接下來的可能我才快的話
7月初還是會有新一波的漲價產生
這邊我就必須要去讚嘆一下
市場的一個效率
我們的節目聽說知道說
雖然我自己是有看到被動元件的趨勢
也有在第一時間跟大家講
可是那時候我有心中的一個OS
跟我實際上講出來的說法是有對到
就是說其實電阻
我感覺它應該是沒有這麼好的一個市場
可是我們最近開始去密集的注意到
R-Chip的一個漲價的趨勢
然後現在已經是怎麼講
有點像是壓不住了
終於要持續的噴射上去
那我自己的猜想是這樣子
因為一開始我們去做這些產業延調的時候
我們就有注意到說
像電阻的駕動率它真的是相對低
就如果說你電容跟電感都沒有噴上去的話
那你去講電阻太怪
因為它那個駕動率就是沒有上去
但可能就是在這一波被動員間
因為終於被市場發現
前面講的時候
你知道其實有很多延調單位
或是很多的全商報告等等
他們都認為說這不會有事情
這擴產很簡單
然後現在開始發現說
有點包不住了
開始要出大事了
火要燒起來了
一些地方採購可能也意識到這件事情
所以我相信可能他的一個
假設我們開上帝視角去看的話
是前面的一些料出現了
被卡住
然後跟叫不到
所以導致說他怕後面的一些料
會不會我動作慢
我也被卡住
所以他立刻的去做加單跟下單
所以才會導致說一些店主
我們也開始發現說
在市場裡面就是它供需的狀況開始變緊甚至有一些漲價先會發出甚至有一些說法之後面的一些漲價的主軸在短期內你會看到的是電阻因為前面的電容已經是相當程度有去做一些漲價
而且有成功的反映到一些大型的EAMS
或是ODM 他們只有接受漲價的
而且中位數的數字
在過去集有跟大家講
中位數的數字是超乎我們的預期
所以電阻後面也會看到一些漲價的產生
功率元件最近的話就向上級跟大家講到
它可能比較偏向是一個產能的問題
必須要去克服
甚至後面會產生的問題是
如果沒有辦法拿到這些
當然最密集使用的
可能是8吋晶圓的話
有可能它的營收獲利
就不一定可以開出來
所以可以掌握
不管是你自己是有垂直代工
去製造晶片的能力
或者是你有去secure到
不管是在一些成熟製程的廠房
或是後段的封車
那就有機會
你在後面可以開出一些成績
所以目前以我們的角度來看的話
整個市場上的結構
並沒有發生太大的轉變
比較平常是
可能前面就漲很多
所以出現一些拉回的現象
市場裡面的利多之所以沒有辦法去對它做驅動
就像是聯發科的漲效線
或者是說像是Triggerfish
額外再多了一個東西
為什麼可能沒有去動或怎麼樣
有可能就是當然前面漲多
然後再來就是
因為其實市場下就是在一個回檔的狀態
所以去看一些東西是不一定是準的
但是其實在今天的尾盤
我覺得已經有注意到一些不一樣的情形
就是開始有一些東西有在拉尾
以我們的角度來講
這些拉尾的東西就有機會會是
假設國際盤在今天晚上穩住
然後明天開始要反攻的話
就會衝第一棒的東西
所以整體來看
像我自己是沒有在部位的
總水位上面去做太多的一個調整
反正以我的想法就是
當今天可能哪些東西
有一些幫痞的狀況產生
我就調一點調一點
但是我會去找新的東西去弄
現在市場給我的一個感受就是
其實新的東西還是非常多
在那邊排隊
所以並沒有到特別緊張的一個感覺
我們也不喜歡當預言家
就是在某個地方去猜說
這裡就是反轉的開始
我覺得這是沒有意義的
反正去做交易或者做投資
就是你看到什麼
你就去做相對的東西
有時候甚至要去把自己的一些
那種敏感度的東西調低一點
因為假設太敏感的話
就像之前跟大家分享
有些人會去用CNN的恐懼貪婪指標
去做交易
那個不太可能
或者想說整天在貼這些東西
搞不好自己不一定有在交易
因為你真的這樣子做的話
你就是每天在最高殺地
簡單來講是這樣
你交易的頻率太高了
所以你根本什麼波段都不用爆了
你是這樣你要做日內當創的話那你不應該是用手動在點所以有一些那種比較短期的訊號其實真的是不用太在意但你可以理解就是因為
市場隨時都有新的人加入
如果當然你是在過去一兩個月加入的
你看到一定覺得說很落賽
我想我身邊朋友開始有些自己的鄰居
密偶說大場面
我想說這個真的不是大場面
這個真的離大場面非常遠
如果說真的大場面出來
應該就往生了
我覺得應該會往生
所以還是要非常小心
那就是說盡量不要因為短線的一些波動的產生
然後就對市場是直接全面的改觀
沒有必要這樣子
就如果你發現你的情緒會在可能兩三個禮拜之間變換三四次以上
應該是哪裡做錯了
應該是哪裡做錯
所以大概跟大家報告一下
就是下市場自己的一些看法
然後跟正在發生這種事情
目前看起來是No Change
沒有什麼特別的變化
比較平常是就長多稍微的休息一下
那後面可能明確的有看到一些新的趨勢
才有辦法再跟大家去做一些剖析
大概就這樣子
好那接下來我們就進入Q的部分
第一位Lan Young
那應該不是L
那應該是I
伊恩 Young
夢宮想請你有猛男的聲音
對台南的士奇說
在台南一個人勃起會不會很孤單啊
有時間上來台北一起印啊
還有想請夢宮報名牌
最愛喝的手搖眼
是哪一家的什麼品項呢
冰塊甜度
感謝夢宮
祝夢宮全家身體健康平平安
以前還是學生時期的時候
非常喜歡喝清新的多多綠
微糖掃冰
那这个是我最有印象的东西
后来稍微的长大一点之后
我就加入了无糖茶的行列
那我后来发现各家的无糖茶
我都可以找到它的故中奥妙
我都会觉得说
它可能有它有趣或是
很赞的一个点
就是我没有办法去帮它分一个稿下
可能今天喜欢喝这家
那明天喜欢喝哪家
所以只要是无糖茶掃冰
对我来讲都是喜欢赞
大概是这样子
林口有一个卖乌龙茶
我暫時忘記他的名字
在Outlet裡面有
烏龍茶的什麼
春茶、清茶什麼的
我覺得都蠻不錯的
還有備茶
就我一直點三種
然後放在冰箱裡面
下面一位
甲賀忍蛙
甲賀甲賀
孟宏宮能夠理解一下
小朋友的六七嗎
他媽媽把他稱什麼
6、7
就是不知道講什麼
就是6、7
不能理解
不曉得諾亞會不會
你會對他比六七的手勢
他搞不好會回應你
請問床蕩到現在
還有恍然大悟的時候嗎
可以聊你在最开始
每增加一位数的心态转变吗
以你相对快的累积速度
当时认知卡很久吗还是很快就掌握再来一次 没有现在的认知你还用当时的打法嗎以及當時的心態是死了算了大不了回去改飛機還是更相信自己的研究策略跟認知
先講前面
就是6-7他是不會
但是他有一個什麼
阿嬤掉進洗衣機
然後什麼阿公打我屁屁
我一直在想說這大概殺小
為什麼他跟他一些同學
在外面都在唱這個
然後後來我去跟
林口父爸爸
就我們林口的一個同業聊天
他說他女兒也會唱這個
可是他女兒跟我兒子的年紀是有一個差距的
所以這好像變成一個那種全球現象還是怎樣
就是全台現象
然後後來我再去問我的健身教練
他的女兒也知道這個
所以對我不知道這是什麼東西
這可能有點類似說以前我們在客家裝
就是會有那什麼歐洲荷蘭義大利墨西哥
不是世俗在
歐洲哈蘭 伊太利亞摩西哥
骯髒的搞完超大一顆沒有洗過
就是那些那種小朋友的go to phrase
然後看到別人就要講這個
就有點類似
他們叫什麼阿嬤掉進洗衣機
什麼阿公拿鍋子打我屁屁
然後就哈哈狂笑
我覺得一點都不好笑
但我還是會稍微配合一下
然後再講說
會不會有恍然大悟的時候
我覺得至今都還是有
甚至是一段時間
沒有那種
我又學到什麼
我又恍然大悟的感覺
我覺得非常失望
這個東西不一定是在
股票跟市場裡面
也有可能是在生活之中
也有可能是在一些
興趣的發展上面
就再說像
我剛剛自己都嚇到
為什麼我開頭
可以跟大家
洋洋灑灑的講說
我對這些東西的看法
就這個東西
其實我入坑沒有多久
但我真的非常認真的研究
所以我就真的有辦法講出一些東西
所以這就是另外一個恍然大物是
我沒有亂花錢
我真的有學到一點東西
所以就還蠻高興的
然後再講說
每增加一位數的心態轉變
其實就只有大概到百到千
蠻有印象的
可是後面都沒有什麼印象
後面數字在網上加都沒有印象
像我今年去
悠悠心辦的一個帳戶
我還跟我老婆開玩笑說
因為她一直講說
你再去弄一個有草地的地方
然後讓球口可以跑
這是她的願望
我說不然這個帳號
你看年底到多少錢
就讓你去做你想要做的事情
就早就打標也是打標數倍
這個是我連想像都不敢想的
當然也沒有覺得很高興
只是你沒有這樣的預期
可是當它真的發生的時候
你也沒有覺得很高興
或者說你的生活型態就改變
就多花錢
它就是工作的一環
那你說當年的感覺是怎麼樣
我記得你當然
你第一次變成百萬的時候
覺得說第一桶金百萬富翁
那只是當然你下去發現說
第一桶金已經在這個時代
好像也不能夠幹嘛
然後後來到千萬的時候
甚至是沒有百萬高興
為什麼
因為到千萬的時候
你肯定認識一些人了
認識一些怪物
所以你會覺得說
我到底在幹嘛
人家賺這麼快我都在幹嘛
那到現在呢
我上面都還是有一大堆的怪物在那邊
那我也不會想要去
怎麼講追上人家或是怎麼樣的
以前會覺得我就是要跟進
那可是我現在的想法是
因為其實對我們來講
生活都是
就夠用了
可以活好幾個輩子了
所以要去做一些有意義的事情
對我來說是這樣
我的人生規劃是
我認為就是不應該只有股票這樣
股票是一個很好的東西
我非常喜歡
我也很熱情的投入
但不應該只有股票
因為我會去假設說
假設我今天掛了
會不會覺得很後悔
我都只有在做同樣一件事情
所以應該要去做更多的事情
總之對我來說
並沒有太多所謂的
思想上的大轉變或是心態轉變
但要用一個比較籠統的方式來說的話
越來越沉默了
以前你可能看到一些東西
會想去跟人家吵架
想去跟人家辯論或什麼的
然後後來你就會知道說
可以救的就是可以救
不能救的就是不能救
你越來越去理解說
每個人都是很屬於在他的這個地方
當你覺得你不屬於這個地方
你要去做改變
你才會跑到下一個地方
不只是心態上
或是面對事情的態度什麼的
對
所以你大概是怎樣的認知
你就會停在什麼地方
之所以我沒有卡很久的一個主因
是因為我算相對幸運
我有認識一些貴人
然後他們會把我往上打
那你各位
也不要覺得你們沒有認識貴人
其實這個節目
當然不要往自己臉上貼金
可是你就想一堆小白跑來聽
什麼都不知道的
我剛剛講說
你就去買個指數就好
隨便買個指數
他就屌幹一堆人的
他把一堆
那麽整天夢想要什麼
全職交易的那麽屌幹在地上
他根本就什麼都沒做
就買那個東西而已
所以嚴格上來說
這個就有幫到你了
你知道我當年是沒有人會跟我講說
可以買這個東西的
我是後來自己知道說
其實0050是可敬的對手
他蠻屌的
有一天我打不贏他我要加入他
所以你知道就有人去點你這些東西就有差
然後再來就是
我覺得這個平台有一個不錯的點是
我自己去吸收到一些東西
我沒有想要去輸出給大家教育大家的意識
因為你們怎麼樣幹我屁事
我不認識你們
但我自己在反處
在思考的過程中
如果你們也可以跟著去吸掉眼東西
那是蠻不錯的
所以像我自己很喜歡的事情是
我反而不喜歡去抓著一個人狂問他問題
我喜歡你就讓我坐在旁邊
我聽你們講話就好
然後最好是我自己也不用講話
我就聽你們講話
類似我去那種品酒會聽人家講話
就學到超多東西
在人家對話之中可以學到蠻多東西
所以對那個心態轉變的話
因為我一直都是抱持著
類似fake it till you make it的心態
不是去假裝成為自己不是的人而是去模仿人家是怎麼樣做所以對我來講我心態轉變沒有到很困難當然絕對數字這個是對每個人來講都是一個挑戰
到現在都還是
你自己靠你自己的日內震盪
震盪的錢可以做什麼事情
你就會覺得說我到底在幹嘛
我怎麼會允許這個震盪發生
可是你也不能夠交往過正
如果說你只想避免這些震盪
變成你什麼小都抱不住
你就不會賺到大錢
你就要一直持續的去辛苦的賺小錢
所以那個確實是一個
需要去調適的東西
會用當時的打法嗎
我覺得我不會去開到太大的槓桿
可是其實我一直以來都算是一個相對保守
我已經跟大家講過很多次
我是沒有被追繳過的人
這個應該是很罕見吧
很多人跟你分享投資什麼
他們都被追繳過
甚至有幾個是破產過什麼的
我不知道去湊人家怎麼樣
我意思是說
那個對我來講是不可以接受的事情
這個是一個很基礎的瘋狂
所以你如果讓我再來一次的話
我還會再更小心
是這樣子
我寧願稍微慢一點
我也不要讓自己有風險
因為你知道現在有蠻多人很流行那一種
反正就是保證金已經全部要用光
打到底那種
你要去想
你在你的人生的範圍內
你一定會遇到幾次
我們隨便舉例
突然川普又決定要去打誰
突然間習近平決定說
我去弄一下金門或什麼的
最後面可能半年後回頭看沒事情
可是當下大恐慌跌停什麼
你知道很多人槓的方式是
他可能一根或是一根半
他會直接歸零
因為他槓的倍數太大了
所以你不要去做那些
可以讓你立刻被秒殺的事情
這個可能是還蠻重要的
所以簡單來講就是這邊
簡單的跟你分享一下
下面一位
Hell 夢光安安
來跟Lisa告白
Lisa臉書會分享收容所黑狗的訊息
本身喜歡動物也喜歡動物的人
愛Lisa
那也想跟大家說
想擁有跟Choco一樣可愛的狗
狗可以多去收容所逛逛
我老婆今天才剛從收容所回來
她真的蠻屌
她每次去收容所
她都會盡可能的把所有狗都帶出去遛一次
就是收容所有兩層
那有些狗在上面的
他們可能就不太想要去抱上面的狗
就有些人去就覺得說
也不怪人家
因為大家媽都已經來幫忙了
已經是很可貴了
每個人體力有限
可是老婆就會有那種很硬氣的態度
媽每次我都要抱下來都要帶出去散步
所以她是真的對狗是付出非常多
我覺得她喜歡狗是遠大於人
或是她老公
大概是這樣
下面一位
憑正留言密碼
老公好
感謝老公製作優質節目
不管這個節目未來有沒有
都希望老公永遠有新東西
可以玩刷爆人生的體驗
最後也祝我太太那四個字
是生日快樂不是你娘卡號
也祝觀眾們績笑噴射
這他講得不錯
然後這個平鎮你的密碼
他大頭貼我是不是在IG有看過你
是不是V開頭的一個兄弟OK我們先祝你太太那四個字你娘卡好也希望她生日快乐非常感谢你对我的祝福永远有新东西玩
对我来讲可能是蛮重要的事情
下面一位
我把你当兄弟
你把我当燕帝
看到尬电工被泼碎物
让我想起
还是那是会晤
就是脏东西
会晤还是碎物
二十几年前
我老爸传授的泼石心法
一石一定要煮过
才能够发挥最大的薰味
二要加入适量油漆
喷洒时才可以附着在建物上
久久不能清理
我好像不应该把这段念出来
因为他把泼石的秘迹教出来
我们这样不要去泼石
你要知道这是违法的行为
还在这边稍微的宣导一下
我刚才也不应该笑的
下面一位
小明孟公安
为什么要来这里教大家泼石
孟公安
我去年去韩国首尔
觉得当地人戾气很重
天天都被路人撞
不管男女老少都敢撞我
177 slash 82超勇的
那今年朋友去回来说
几次被陌生路人请客结账
说股票赚很多
是我性别错误
还是韩国人股市赚太多
SK海力士8月要在美国上ADR了
你认为解码美光配置一部分吗
谢谢孟公
我没有办法给大家买进与否的建议
那我自己已经很久没有再去买进
记忆体股票
就算美光有一些报纸这样
那后来都在弄别的题材
你喜欢当然你就多买一点没有关系
然后再来讲说
韓國人力氣很重
這個我在可能幾年前的節目
就跟大家講
因為我老婆那段時間很喜歡去韓國
她喜歡去韓國逛街
然後或者去弄一些醫美
不是整形
然後跟我講說
你也跟大家講說弄醫美
大家又有整形
我老婆沒有在做整形
她就是可能去打一些東西
讓皮膚看起來亮晶晶這樣子
那她那時候蠻喜歡去韓國的
因為他們怎麼講
就是說蠻多老外都是
被韓國的文化影響
她們很喜歡去
那一開始去我自己都是非常不悅
所以那時候節目
就是很多時候要跟大家去
找到一些東西
然後來說服我自己有什麼在韓國
我喜歡吃醬蟹
我喜歡什麼
但是我其實超級不喜歡去韓國
韓國真的是一個
對男生來講很無聊的地方
可是老婆可能會很喜歡的地方
他們喜歡去逛那邊
什麼Oliver tree
還是什麼Oliver
Oliver什麼
Oliver Young
Oliver Young不是Oliver Tree
反正他們就是有很多東西可以玩
那一開始都只是我在抱
有辦法說他們的人是比較兇一點的
然後再來就是
你去坐計程車的時候
應該在韓國有坐過計程車
不是只有一次的
你多坐幾次你一定會遇到
那機率太高了
因為我就整天都搭計程車
所以我非常的理解
他們超喜歡油門煞車乾您老實我想說以前我們在開車的時候我這樣開車我一定給我爸幹的我一定給我阿嬤幹的我阿嬤想說你開車是怎樣你最後面那個煞車輕輕點然後最後面要有點像滑行的姿態
甚至連停車的感覺都感覺不到
他們沒有在屌你
油門煞車
所以你在韓國就是很多事情都讓你不願
然後後來有一次
我不是去改搭另外一個機場嗎
因為我朋友跟我講說
那個機場怎麼離市區比較近比較快
不要去首爾的那個人船
要去那個機場
忘記叫什麼
反正我就跑那個機場去
然後我第一次覺得
我可能會死在那邊
他就讓一堆人擠到手機全部擠滿
我想說他們又發生什麼離太院什麼有的沒有的
就韓國真的是很多時候會給你那種
就是我可能會死在這個地方的感覺
然後不然說像之前有一次去
也是遇到那種暴風雪
然後什麼小都叫什麼車都叫不到
然後還收到那個簡訊通知告訴你說
要小心從北韓過來這邊的高空氣球
我去找翻譯那個高空氣球
它裡面寫裝的裝大便
他們裝大便然後來這邊空投
我覺得說這個地方真的很有想法
我真的很不喜歡
然後後來是我老婆有一次去做SPA
然後給人家詐騙
真的是被詐騙被拐錢
人家拐他錢
那Ajuma拐他錢
他超不爽
他跑出來跟我講一直哭
我想說我進去要把他跟他輸贏
想說算了我們後面還有行程
你到底想怎麼樣
心中有去閃過一絲念頭
要不要報警
後來才想到人家跟我講過
你在韓國報警
他們只會挺自己人
所以你不用報警了
你那個效率也超低
怎麼辦
我就跟Ajuma說
你現在要多少錢
他說他那個錢
我直接說我只要付你一半
你要不要收
他想說OK
Card or cash
我會覺得說
幹你媽真的一群不能收
所以那時候去的印象不太好
但有時候還是會想到那個地方
因為還是有好的人
只是就是他有很多地方會讓你覺得
你會被冒犯
你會很不爽
他們是一個很競爭的地方
我感覺跟去香港有點像
就是他們給我的感覺很像
就是一個
就是他們大家都在
你知道
Fighting
Everyday fighting
他們可能壓力真的很大
給你的那個感受是不太好的
但我有聽說
就是最近可能
蠻多韓國人股票賺很多錢
生意率也拉起來了
說不定變成一個不一樣的地方
有空再去
當我老婆那一次被氣到
罵再也不要去韓國
大概這樣
下面一位 FAU
夢宮很幸運
可以選擇要mute掉哪些人
說不見面就不見面
說不看留言就不看留言
但對某些人而言
很多情緒的來源根本就無法忽略
例如某些教授情緒管理有問題
把底下的研究生當狗在幹
但為了畢業只能夠忍氣吞聲
又例如主管開會常常暴氣
當大家的面巴你罵一文不值
但為了生活你依然不能夠選擇離職
瓜哥不確定的因素太大
家計因素等等的
此時似乎只剩暴露療法可以治療玻璃心
但每次我看到主管爆氣摔東西的時候
還是會想拿東西督進他的身體裡
好啦 我只是說說祝夢宮一生平安
兒子女兒們都不會遇到這種激掰人
這位FAU名字取得好
剛好也是現在很紅的
Fiber Array Unit的一個縮寫
他說的沒錯
應該不能夠說幸運
是說我自己很有意識的
讓我不要去依賴任何東西
嚴格上來說
你去做股票的人
像我們身邊有蠻多
他們就必須要去依附一些組織
那就變成你還是有老闆
即便他們已經可以獨立作戰
但他們就還是有去
我就是一直告訴我自己
絕對不能夠去
就即便你可能有提升的機會
但我不要
我寧願就算慢一點
會沒有關係
我也不要去
再來就是像有這個節目
有些人可能也會
為了要去維持自己的流量怎麼樣
有些話我不能講
被罵了我就要去修正我自己
然後不然就是怕惹到什麼
業配廣告的廠商
小弟就是反正我講才聽一點
你媽你要來干擾我做事情的話
我寧願就不要做了
所以我隨時抱持著失去一切的準備
我覺得是因為這樣子
所以才可以過現在自己想要的一個生活
我非常感謝我老婆在這一路的扶持
為什麼
因為其實我最早在做一些事情的時候
其實我也是沒有自信認為說我自己可以
所以我會想要去
就像說像有些飯局
我就認為我一定要去
我老婆就會說其實你不需要去
或是像以前我可能在上班的時候
因為我跟我老婆認識的時候
我還是有在工作
我老婆那時候就會跟我講說
其實你根本不需要幫那個人工作
因為怎麼樣
然後那時候我都覺得說
只是他吃醋
他不想要我出去什麼的
然後後來才懂
就是我其實真的不需要這些人
但如果他沒有給我這個勇氣的話
我覺得按照我被養大的方式
或是我所在的環境
我有可能我真的還在一些地方工作
或是我會去屈居於一些地方
或甚至是說
就在說他自己有一點聲量
理論上可以決定一點東西
可是你看很多人還是
他今天被罵一下
他就立刻出來跟大家道歉
可是我被罵
你看我都直接幹回去
你們真的有些人要cancel的話
你就去cancel
我反而會希望說
我有照一日假設我被cancel
你們會出來幫我講話
然後讓我不被cancel
但如果說真的沒有人要幫我講話
我真的要被cancel
那就大家拜拜
就是我抱持這個心態
我覺得說幹你要罵
誰也不欠誰
沒事就沒有什麼太大的問題
我希望大家有照一日
都可以走向這樣子的一個方向
就是為自己工作為自己負責
我也希望我孩子是這樣
我不希望他未來可能大富大貴
或是要去哪裡當CEO什麼
我只希望他開一個
小漫畫店之類的他可以養活他自己就要或甚至是他不一定可以養活他自己爸爸會幫他之類因為反正家裡一定會留一點東西給他後來就注意到像我們身邊有些你可以去酸人家富二代靠爸
可是人家爸爸爸就真的很認真
然後就讓他
他真的可以做他喜歡做的事情
然後家裡都會去支持他
我覺得資本主義的社會就是一個接力賽
所以就持續的把這個東西傳下去
就希望他以後也不用去面對
可能當時我也曾經面對過的東西
就我最早
像我去幫人家工作的時候
我也是有蠻多委屈
只是有些東西不能在節目上拿出來去吐
因為那有些是什麼前老闆
我那個機師的東西拿出來吐
是因為真的太生氣了
所以拿出來吐
但有些東西我就也不會再講
就有啦 一定也有吃過
就是你吃過那些東西
你就是發誓自己在
不要再吃那些東西
所以才會走出來
然後也發誓
我不要讓我孩子去忍受這種委屈
我以前在學校什麼
訓導主人把我壓在地上
然後拿噴條打我
以後誰敢打我小孩
他媽試看看
我一定去打你
下面一位
旋轉龜頭 夢攻無安
請問功能性訓練對主委的體態或訓練
有何實質性的幫助
住家附近的健身旁教練會功能性訓練的
比不會的費用差了幾千塊
在想要不要紙上感謝回覆
然後近期社群上充斥大量的AI圖
真的很夠煩耶
拜託主委用多米多羅的語氣說
我不會學多米多羅
我只知道他那個背棄耶
好啦 那那個功能性訓練有什麼實質的幫助
我至今其實我是蠻密集的上課
大概一個禮拜會尻到兩到三堂去
雖然並沒有說上了什麼半年一年
可是至今對我的改變是非常顯著的
我覺得首先就是你注意到
你的關節活動度變得很好
然後再來是你在做一些發力的時候
就要說你在網球的運用上面
你發現說你打得比之前更好
你會知道說怎麼樣發力
你不會說什麼打完就只有手在酸
你會全身的肌肉都會有辦法去做運用
知道怎麼樣踩地
然後到寬
然後到腰
到你的左胸可能拉出去
然後右手再把它帶出去
就是你會有辦法去解構你的身體
甚至是我講一個最北欄的
我每天早上醒來
然後可能去刷牙
去把那個維持器拿下來
再洗的時候
以前你不知道
所以你可能長期有一些背痛的問題
可是後來你就發現說
我今天這樣站的時候
我感覺我背不太對
所以你會挪動一兩截脊椎
我很難去形容那種感覺
但你現在有辦法抓到說
我知道我身體要怎麼樣站
我現在的重心就不會說
是在不對的地方
導致我的腰在承受我的重量
我即便我只是在那邊洗東西
或是洗水果
我都知道說OK我現在腰要怎麼樣站所以我覺得很讚我非常喜歡但有可能是我教練是鬼神因為我已經在健身房裡面物色他很久了我就已經雖然這樣講起來有點那種
難分難捨的感覺
就是有一種那種gay感
但我就是一直知道說
那個人他不太一樣
所以他有可能
因為我後來才知道說
他是很厲害的人
然後就是
他是很多人的教練
他是教練的教練
類似這樣
所以有可能我是遇到極屌的人
這個我不排除
但以他教我的東西
他把它稱為是功能性
或者技能性训练
我觉得是超级值得去学的东西
那对你有没有用
很简单
你就付点钱去上课
没有用就立刻跳
就这样就好
因为这个东西理论上
像我自己是学不到
一两个礼拜
我立刻就发现不一样
所以可以去试试
给这个旋转龟头参考一下
下面一位
波波爱上梦工
这集的标题可以用白菜吗
OK
梦工去咖安安
最近重看福利联有个感受
辛梅尔那么认真的留下
旁人以为的自恋
但其实那个都是爱的痕迹
即便福利连在遥远的将来才感受到
我就觉得如果我是诺雅安哥
在未来某天听到爸爸节目是这样爱着我们
我一定会感动到落泪
那人是不是上了年纪
类线就会变发达呢
野猪梦公
祝我早日遇到生命中的爱人爱你
我觉得这个就是很讽刺一点
就是你不太确定
有照一日你儿子是会谢谢你
还是会讨厌你
但是我尽量不要去做一个
可能会被讨厌的父亲
我尽量当我孩子有需要的时候
我就会立刻在那边
可是我同时我也知道
我不能够闯坏他
不能讓他依賴我
他還是要獨立
所以有時候還是要鼓勵他
結果就把他丟到水裡面
希望他會游泳之類的
當然我們會去幫他做好一些訓練
所以那個收放之間
是我被身為這種父親的幾位兄弟們
聽眾們
大家都在學習的東西
我們希望我們都可以當一個
這個至少孩子
我覺得媽如果說我掛掉
我是真的可以
就是靈魂會飄出身體下
他一定要趴在我身上狂哭
就是我一定要看到這個畫面
我就覺得我是一個成功的父親
大概這樣子
然後再來前面講說
心沒而留下旁人以為的自戀
這點我突然有一個想法
但跟其他東西可能不一定有關
我以前也會去思考說
我今天講的一些東西
就算說我自己以下還是有一些群組
不管是股票朋友或是怎麼樣的朋友
我會覺得說我會不會在這邊講太多了
我現在會不會去評論太多了
或是我現在講的東西會不會怎麼樣之類
我有很多那種懷疑自己
我覺得以前有這樣子的想法是好的
你確實不要去干擾大家或怎麼樣
可是後來我現在越來越自我
也有可能是年紀到
你知道一些長輩後來就不管人家了走路走一走順便水屁之類的或者說什麼亂插隊我們不要踏到那個極端可是我們可以從保守這邊去稍微往光譜的中間站一點也就是你現在想說什麼就說什麼
你想跟他說我愛你
就說我愛你
就即便可能有點gay沒有關係
你就是想說什麼
你當下就是立刻說什麼
然後即便可能當下
看起來很尷尬或是很奇怪之類的
但你不會有任何的遺憾
然後有一天可能大家回想
就會發現他記得你那時候講過什麼
有了沒有的東西
所以總之就是
很自我
但這個自我不是負面那種
你去傳達你想要去傳達的任何東西
我認為他讓我想到這件事情
那或許Cmail就是他就是在
傳達他的自己的一些感受
然後讓這個人看起來是非常的令人印象深刻
甚至你後來會懷念他
類似說有些朋友你會去抱怨說
每次找他來話最多很吵
可是他不在的時候你就會想念他
希望大家可以來這邊多講一點話之類的
下面一位
John
孟公想問你美股光通占比美股的比例高嗎
印象中你有提過Cohereen、Lumenton跟Marvell
有沒有哪個比較喜歡
像是光通測試的VIVTR
想問Teradon喜歡
非常喜歡
想問你對Nokia有研究嗎
想聽聽你的看法
Nokia 我記得之前有一次有跟大家聊到
它好像跑去GAM另外一個
也在做光線還是什麼的Share
它有機會在CSP裡面拿到一些東西
光通目前的比例是低的
因為後來我就跑去買CPU跟其他東西
有一段時間是很高沒錯
然後我最喜歡的就是
Nomantown跟Cohereen
MARVIA我甚至不會把它放在光通這裡面
就是大家都說要切啦
只是我不會把它放在純度高這裡面
然後再來講說一些像Terry打這樣的東西
這個都是可以持續去關注
我也蠻喜歡的
那Nokia的話
對它是有一些轉機的產生
它不是像大家想像的手機
也不是像大家想像的基地台
開始有去切一些比較酷的業務啦
那最近是比較沒有在看光通了
所以有些新的update
可能沒有辦法在這邊跟大家做很詳盡的更新
我們還是會跟著市場下一些主流題材去走
大家這樣
下面一位
伊隆馬
派夢宮去卡預計年底要去當兵
手上的部位只要是長線為主
又有一小部分短線的部分
進去前建議把短線的部位出掉換大盤的ETF嗎
如果你會一直想看的話
當然就是換一換比較好
不然你可能會心神不擬
只剩下一點時間
我們念個短的
哀真實獵人
預設高低點大盤色滿臉
我有一件Cyberpunk的古IT都捨不得穿
希望GTA6可以找夢功復刻一鍵
有諾亞安哥LISA版本的一定買爆
那一講突然間很多回憶出來
就是我自己是還蠻喜歡這些遊戲的
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕